faire beaubourg c'est un succès c'est un
double succès car non seulement il
affiche complet mais encore beaucoup de
visiteurs avoue n'être jamais entré
auparavant dans un musée 45 jours
d'ouverture est aujourd'hui un million
de visiteurs le millionième visiteur ça
se fête
c'est ce que l'on a fait au centre
national d'art et de culture georges
pompidou
cet après midi
blanche célestine des noms qui évoquent
les vieilles dentelles les confitures
faites maison
des noms qui sentent la violette le
muguet et les refrains d'antan et de
dame charmante rencontré au pied de
beaubourg totalise 163 en l2 j'habite
paris
et j'ai fait le tour du monde dans toute
ma vie monsieur la femme d'à pétroliers
je suis en visite à paris pour sa vie et
peuple que vous allez gagner mes matches
pour vous le rejetez vous faut pas être
attarine pas voir tout le monde enfin
toutes mes amies moines ont parlé leur
ai dit il faut y aller faut parce que
c'est notre adn des éléments la peinture
mais la sculpture mais je ne sais pas la
salers et la peinture moderne
vous avez trois otages avaient tous deux
sont particulièrement depuis un 2e étage
je pense qu'une petite fille c'est rami
valence d'ailleurs
d'unités par an la droite a déjoué mâché
ses mots
regardez moi c'est parce que ça mais
vous avez vous ça regardez comme c'est
drôle c'est une fausse gaza a c'est vrai
voyez c'est un bénin le ghana catala
mais non c'est plus mais c'est faux
c'est une fausse façade de la peur est
un
ma première abuse c'est pas bon ça me
fait penser à un bateau de guerre
oui d'accord et nous vivons dans un
siècle de d'armature et de ferraille et
de tout ce que vous voulez de vitres
sales